in Ghana an artist prepares his tools to
create another Masterpiece he mounts his
canvas prepares his brushes mixes his
paints but what is he
painting wait is that alucino a horse's
head is that a burning car oh it's the
Godfather got
it so you're probably wondering why
these posters look different well in
the' 70s and ' 80s in Ghana when video
cassettes arrived locals would create
DIY pop-up Cinemas using whatever
technology they could get their hands on
these Cinemas needed to advertise their
films and with hand painted Graphics
being the norm back then plenty of
talented artists Rose to the challenge
using discarded flower sacks as their
canvas so my name is Joseph frong I'm
the director for the center for African
popular culture at chassi I'm also a
researcher and a collector I think the
reactions to these um exhibitions can be
classified into two folds for the older
generation it evokes feelings of
nostalgia right and people say oh you
know I used to remember you know these
works when I was younger etc etc and
then you have the younger folks who have
no experience with it and then they
begin to ask questions this is weird or
this is strangely artistic uh where is
this coming from as competition grew
stronger the paintings got more dramatic
often featuring graphic scenes and
exaggerated muscular
physiques sometimes you have things
depicted on the posters that will arouse
your interest because you think that you
are going to see those depictions in
those uh movies it created tensions
where you have certain folks demanding
their money back because they've been
deceived right they use a process called
imaginative painting where they take
artistic Liberties to sometimes render
things that you not see in the movies it
makes them truly truly unique with the
rise of digital printed posters in the
2000s handpainted posters fell out of
fashion but frong believes they're worth
holding on to and it's not just him in
fact Ganan poster painters have found a
new audience around the
world I think the art form hasn't
changed rather the purpose of these
posters has changed it was used to
advertise movies now that experience is
non-existent so these Works have now
become Collectibles these posters have
gained a cult fan base globally usually
selling for around $800 a piece there
are even counterfeit posters out there
artists now create commission pieces of
their clients favorite films in their
signature style something about these
posters continues to resonate with
people I mean I can see why who wouldn't
want a handp painted poster of their
favorite film where all of the
characters are jacked and there's a few
additional grenades thrown in for fun I
mean look at those muscles
[Music]
Wild